- Vivre loin des autres comme
ça, dans le bois, on était
très bien. On pouvait partir
n'importe quand se promener.
Ça dérangeait pas personne.
Ça nous manque à toute la gang.
- Serge Simard aime rouler
quelques kilomètres pour
se rendre dans son coin
de paradis avec sa famille.
Il a travaillé pendant deux ans
pour construire la résidence
familiale, deux ans d'efforts
envolés en fumée
le 2 mars dernier.
SERGE SIMARD, papa de Samuel
- Une épreuve terrible. Ah oui,
je souhaite ça à personne,
parce qu'on perd tout, tout,
tout au complet. C'était énorme,
C'était... c'était gros...
Ça l'est encore.
- Tôt le matin, son fils
de 8 ans, Samuel, aperçoit
quelque chose d'inhabituel.
SAMUEL SIMARD,
- On était en train de dormir.
Moi, il fallait que j'aille
au toilette. Puis là, j'ai vu
de la lumière au plafond. Fait
que j'ai levé papa et maman.
- Nous, on dormait tous par
en arrière là-bas. Puis c'est là
que Samuel s'est levé et a vu le
feu dans le pignon en haut là.
- Puis en haut des marches,
ça brûlait. On a eu le temps
de tous sortir.
- Est-ce que vous avez eu
le temps de sortir des choses
ou même pas?
- Rien! Rien, ça a été dehors.
C'était fini.
- Tous les membres de la famille
sont sains et saufs. Six vies
sauvées grâce au garçon.
La députée de Roberval a tenu à
souligner sa vivacité d'esprit.
NANCY GUILLEMETTE,
députée, CAQ, Roberval
- C'est pourquoi, j'honorerai
Samuel Simard, 8 ans,
en lui remettant la médaille
de l'Assemblée nationale
pour son courage et sa présence
d'esprit, pour sa bravoure,
ayant permis de sauver
tous les membres de sa famille
le 2 mars dernier.
- La remise de cette distinction
rend son papa très fier.
- J'étais très touché, t'sais
quand même, qu'ils donnent ça
à mon garçon. Même lui, t'sais
ça a fait : hein, c'est vrai que
c'est un héros. Il nous a tous
sauvés. Avec du recul, tu vois
ça. C'était plaisant de
leur part de le mentionner.
Parce qu'il va être marqué
le restant de ses jours, Samuel,
de nous avoir sauvés de même.
Dans sa face, tu le vois
qu'il est fier.
- Les citoyens de Ste-Hedwidge
ont été nombreux à donner
des vêtements et d'autres
articles pour venir en aide
à la famille qui a tout perdu
lors de l'incendie.
Et malheureusement,
elle n'avait pas encore souscrit
à une assurance habitation.
Le clan Simard a récemment
acheté un terrain pour
se construire une nouvelle
maison à Roberval,
tout en souhaitant retrouver
le plus tôt possible, un pied-à-
terre sur leur terre familiale.
Ici Laurie Gobeil,
Radio-Canada, Sainte-Hedw